hey this is presh talwalkar
in a group of six people
you might find out that some people are
friends on facebook
or you might find out that no one is
friends on facebook
there are many different combinations
for how people can be friends or not
friends on facebook
but there is always a special property
that's true
show that there is always a group of
three people where either
all three people are mutual friends on
facebook
or
all three people are strangers
no one is friends on facebook
give this prom a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we can visualize the problem using graph
theory
imagine each person is the vertex of a
graph
we will draw six vertices for the six
people in the group
we will draw a blue line between two
vertices to represent if the two people
are friends and we will draw a red line
between two vertices to represent if the
two people are not friends
from a given vertex
we can have between zero and five blue
lines which is accompanied by five to
zero red lines
we're going to draw five lines from one
vertex
and whichever lines are not blue will
have to be red
so from this one vertex we will always
have one two
three four or five blue lines or zero
blue lines
and whichever lines are not blue will be
red
so if we have four blue lines we'll have
one red line
if we have three blue lines we'll have
two red lines and so on the number of
red lines and blue lines always adds up
to five
because of this we will always have at
least three blue lines or at least three
red lines
we'll consider each case separately
let's first consider that there are at
least three blue
lines what we do now is we'll look at
the vertices which are connected by blue
lines we'll look at the friends of this
person
if any of these two people are friends
we will form a group of three people in
which all three are mutual friends
in other words we will graphically have
a blue triangle these are three people
who are mutual friends
what would happen if none of them are
friends
well in that case we would have to draw
a red line between each of these three
vertices
this would represent that these three
people are not friends with each other
on facebook so we formed a red triangle
which means these three people are
mutual strangers
so we've proven that we will always have
at least three mutual friends or at
least three mutual strangers
now let's consider the other case where
we have at least three or more red lines
now we'll look at the connected vertices
in other words we'll look at the people
who are not friends with this person
now if none of these people are friends
with each other if any of these people
are strangers
we're going to form a red triangle we'll
have three mutual strangers
the other case
is that all of these people are friends
with each other
in that case we'll have to connect these
three vertices with blue lines which
means these are three people who are
mutual friends
so what we've shown by considering these
two cases is that no matter how we draw
this graph no matter how these six
people are friends or not friends we
always end up with a group of three
people
who are mutual friends
that's a blue triangle or we have three
people who are mutual strangers which is
a red triangle it's always going to be
true
this is sometimes known as the
friendship theorem and it's an example
of ramsay theory
did you figure out this puzzle
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions which you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description